[Music]
Nadeem I am so glad you're here because
I know you are a cat owner I am also a
cat owner not a cat or now it was just
fostering Jake Katy went away
oh you hoser how cozy I was at saving
lives I don't own them
oh you don't okay yeah the Gallagher
garnish so you're not a real cat guy
yeah well there's a study now that gave
me a lap dude that she was weak what lap
can run around the [ __ ] bills
replenishment for a bad joke cuz we say
a lap as in in my language like him hit
you so I thought that made sense to me
too but you idiots Mac for saying
something so stupid
cool yeah get one of those to go do a
laugh and get a laugh laugh yeah alright
there is a study saying and tell me if
you guys agree or disagree that men who
are cat owners they don't get the [ __ ]
nope are less mass less masculine then
dog owners mint male dog owners I'm not
I'm not your typical female so because
of that I would agree with this so me
you should probably ask a typical female
though when they did they did have one
where your own strip chat about strip
chat the legs open you think of guys
with cats they agree with everything I
say funny imagine if I wasn't allergic
I'd own a cat yeah but I also own a
giraffe if I could there goes the organ
Oh animal yeah I don't know what would
you start with first
like with a dog right a dog first
multiple dogs but I think because dogs
have a special connection with me like I
think like humans and dogs we know each
other so why is it that because everyone
kind of thinks it right why is it a cat
seems less masculine why is it why is it
like Oh like we should know with
Christmas articles going right now if we
can just start talking about that white
my cats are less masculine because I
know again I don't want cat but at the
same time I'm like guys who just like
I'm gonna get a cat instead you're like
mmm feed Lions just probably have like a
feminine energy
to them yeah even guy cats kind of have
like I guess like traditional but like
like stereotypically you know like guys
they basically like dogs chase the cat I
like get like guys or act like dogs do
they always want to have sex whatever
whatever and I think cats are being
chased around so just I guess as
symbolism animals it seem like cats are
just more female yeah right and the
others name yeah and I think from those
old thoughts came that well what's more
masculine if I get a cat because I know
a lot of it goes I don't want to hook up
with have cats and they'll want to come
over to meet my kitty
and then I [ __ ] them that's smart terms
cousin I call it Achilles Illinois oh
that's also game they come on there
immediately friend zone but you [ __ ]
them know you'd be the better this I
would say I'm like man you're like the
brother I wish I had yeah when you have
a cat have a castle as far as like using
a pet to get chicks dogs exactly and I'd
like also the dog is easier to be like
this is my pet because it's like a
loving thing exactly they're people you
usually an [ __ ] you pedal a scratch
you might bite you you know or he's
really nice who knows I just saw it as
like introverts like cats and extroverts
like dogs know I'm introverted I like I
think I'm more introverted and I like
dog straight through and through would
be dog all the way right but then like
if I lived in an apartment and I just
wanted like a pet and get a rat or a
hamster snow snake I wouldn't trust
someone that just has that if I could
have a zoo I have a zoo okay but with
the cat thing we're talking about my dog
[Laughter]
it's easy to take care they're so easy
right it's like not even having a pit
it's almost like that yeah which is why
I only have one no they just don't have
a bit holy it's like the stuff that I'm
trying to do right now with my life I'm
out for a long time is it like I can't
be here and just leave a dog like
they're like go on it's more of a
liability I could go like oh my dog so
probably barking his life away no he's
not he's great he's a well trained
yes he's sitting home he's chillin I
know he's good smoking a cigar
yeah he's easily like you waiting for me
to come home he's all excited if I come
home to a cat I look at maybe like I
don't give a [ __ ] if he came back still
alive you know Wow thought you were gone
train them cuz you had a lot of like
your work was on social media at home
you a was that like if I if I wasn't
trying to go out constantly and do all
those things I would definitely thought
I could take care of especially the
small excuse I'm me before I got a dog
was like I can't take no matter what
whatever you gave then you're gonna have
to yeah you just figure it out look I
would rather have like a cat like the
cats
I was also forced on the cat's cousin I
have save them okay yeah so it's like I
would never have thought of getting a
cat first right I was always like if
someone needed your slain [ __ ] dude
yeah it's easy just like that saving
[ __ ] same [ __ ] and but then now once
I've had them and on them I might do
there's so much easier and there's still
fun they play around maybe they're just
all kittens so that was just like easy
but maybe that's part of why it's like a
little bless respected well maybe is it
easier is this like a generational thing
like maybe is Gen Z going like no that's
completely false and like girls are like
dude I would totally play a guy that
that's okay oh man you can't walk a cat
you can I mean not you shouldn't also
when you think of like a badass right
like someone in the front of a album
cover it's like got it like the game
with [ __ ] three pit bulls
yeah and that's masculine you know
picture the game with like three kittens
unleashing a game-changer though it
would be but that this certificado be
him with a Jaguar on his shoulder like
maybe even taking like the masculine
feminine thing out of it maybe it's just
like why are you why cat it's a question
maybe it's a question every it's like a
chicks like why'd you get a cat instead
of a dog and I don't know the answer to
that there's some people that just like
cats yeah but you are easy to take care
of well a case is allergic to dogs I'm
allergic to dogs but you would probably
prefer I prefer gaim and her
I've always wanted a pet that would
follow me around but cats never do
[ __ ] goldfish don't [ __ ] do that
turtles don't do that I'm pretty bitter
but there is an answer job I think I
should get a mug like why a cat you know
like you need to ask why and that's
that's the thing maybe it's like you
know there is that state you typically
have to like that over a dog to get one
like if you're gonna get one there is
one thing I like about cats over dogs is
that cats actually smell like good like
they clean themselves yeah baby yeah
they don't have this sauce you know good
if you should smell fun not all dogs dog
I've ever encountered have the habit of
a dog smell yeah they're as smells - why
would you smell a blackboard I'm not
trying to know the head in the neck it
smells so good there but then cats like
baby poo in the litter box and they
clean up if they take care of you could
be gone for a while you'd like you don't
have to take them out sounds lazy to me
if I was allergic gotta have one
but I'd have a dog - I'm I'll go to dog
but I disagree with this article because
I don't find myself that masculine but I
think that showed of dog first and
foremost no one would ever not think
you're mad you're so [ __ ] masculine
what are you talking barriers man yeah
you're so masculine you drink cheers
shower Cheers
that's right yeah me I don't know I
don't know if I agree with the article
by get where it's condom or a thing like
we all understand our group of girls and
they showed the photo of a guy just by
himself and they were rating that guy on
his masculinity and they're surely
saying same photo earnest the same guy a
different photo but with the cat in his
arms now and from the survey the
masculinity levels dropped I don't want
you to do I need to see the dog because
if it's a [ __ ]
Labrador or whatever and it's next to
him or like a pitbull that's in it and
is it a puppy what if you had a puppy
and he's holding it just like a cat
nobody's different though it feels
nurturing wait I think the breed is what
you're getting like a teacup
matter I don't know if the size or the
age we've had a teacup poodle and the
other one the cat was like a [ __ ]
links or some [ __ ] like a tiger tiger no
a cat's a [ __ ] cat or one of those
exotic cats
no like is a lemur a cat no for myself
right and I like a very I like a very
masculine kind by masculine I'd like him
to be athletic I like him to have a big
bag like they're very specific features
and lifestyles that I like right he will
hold a cat though not again for me right
if I'm looking at that picture then if I
see the guy with the dog I'm like all
cool this guy probably walks his dogs
they probably go on adventures
he has a buddy to play with he play
fetch like he's got a Pomeranian I'm
creating a life oh yeah that's true that
it's a kind of dog right it's a brief
for sure it's the breed but then if I
see a cat a guy with the cat and that's
his baby then I'm like damn this guy
might cry after we upset I'm so [ __ ]
old school thinking like I just need to
evolve my [ __ ] but that's just where I'm
at is it old school though because it
just sounds like you have a preference
that's true and what you find masculine
is a guy that is more physically like
warrior looking yeah I think she just
means as far as like the animal choice
for oh yeah like this stigma as far as
like wait what your animal choice says
it because you can look like a buff yeah
but if he has a cat it's kind of
something different yeah there's
something that I just think I'm like I
feel like we're not gonna gel what about
a peacock though Matt sick is [ __ ] yeah
say like I think the also limited to
just feminine and masculine because if
they opened it up right there's a guy
with a parrot no a guy with the possum a
guy with the raccoon yeah you know
wouldn't be so masculine feminine it's
more of like what personality type is
this the lizard though not now
really why is that I mean if he takes it
out in public some people just have him
on the shoulder
that's what I would not be
maybe that guess is like trying to
figure out what what is it that it says
about you it yeah whether it's true or
not it's like no I'm asking famine or
whatever it's like what does it say
about you like your choices why you got
that mm-hmm so having a kid does that
make make it you seem like you're a
boring person then no seems like it's
sensitive exactly
okay you don't want a sensitive man but
it's also like I like medium to largest
sized dogs cuz I like them they feel
like my my buddy my piece love dogs
small I love them but that not for me
because it feels like a pet yeah little
thing that I take care of versus like my
dog feels like my buddy like my pal
Marissa it's like we can you know we're
like boys it's like a small dog on my
vest my pet gotta take care of that
thing I hold it it's like we'll tie
anything cat kind of the same way but
also doesn't really care about you what
about our gazelle no like we're all
writing [ __ ] bicycles down this Lane
down the park we're all looking at each
other's bikes oh my [ __ ] yeah you cut
with the unicycle trying to join the
pack we're like pro we don't get it
comes in unicycle across either
[Laughter]
[Music]